I'm just really disappointed in Tristan
this was
just really unforgivable in my books
it's almost like he wanted to trap her
Kendall and Kylie Jenner slamming
Tristan Thompson after as they say he
trapped their sister Chloe into having
another baby like everything happened
and she was just like it gets worse yeah
on the season 2 premiere of the
Kardashians the family addresses
Tristan's latest cheating scandal
head-on this time he encouraged Chloe
move forward with an embryo transfer to
a surrogate while knowingly expecting a
child with another woman who he got
pregnant months before why would I want
to have a baby with someone who's having
a baby with somebody else and this is
the Kardashians we're talking about you
know that blood is thick and Chloe's
little sister's Kendall and Kylie didn't
mince words during a family discussion
about the situation I think it's really
[ __ ] up that he knew he had another
baby on the way with somebody else which
makes me uncomfortable to put someone in
that position especially when there's a
child involved I hate that she's sad
I just love my sister and I hate that
she's you know going through this the
sisters call out Tristan for trapping
Chloe claiming the timeline of events
tells all
Tristan knew that this was happening is
like you were you were encouraging Chloe
to go forward with this while you knew
that that was also happening it's almost
like he wanted to trap her so let's
rewind and look at how it all unfolded
July 2021 Tristan finds out he's having
a baby with Marley Nichols he found out
July 2nd so he did know then fast
forward a couple months and Tristan and
Chloe begin the embryo transfer process
to their surrogate we did an embryo
transfer like days before Thanksgiving
but just days later
oh my God this cannot be happening the
bombshell drops that Tristan's having a
baby with another woman I found out
about Tristan's situation the first week
of December I mean it's supposed to be a
really exciting amazing time and it's
just
a different experience I think yeah and
that different experience had Coco's
Mama Chris in tears I want you to enjoy
it they don't want you to miss it
because you can't you can't do it over I
just I just feel bad for her
that
it the joy was kind of sucked out of it
again you know but Chris wasn't the only
emotional one I just know that
everything's been so hard for you and
that just makes me really sad for you
and
you're just there's no one that deserves
happiness like you do thank you
seriously and if you can't see it now
like this baby is gonna bring you so
much love and joy and happiness but
those dark clouds turn to Sunshine When
Chloe welcomed her baby boy in August
you can turn your life around you can go
through hell and high water but you can
still come out and despite the drama
Tristan celebrated the birth with her
Tristan wants to be here so I just
figured why not let him come I'll never
get this moment back
foreign